[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this morning on the dish inat admoni she
is a culinary trailblazer with an
innovative approach to middle eastern
cuisine and also the venues where it's
served our nancy chen is here with her
story hi nancy hey good morning to you
adriana that's right after starting the
falafel chain taim she opened kishkash
new york city's first couscous bar now
she executes higher end dishes at her
acclaimed israeli restaurant balabusta
and her signature dishes can be found in
two best-selling cookbooks i joined her
at balaboosta for a taste
for chef enot oddmoney taking life by
the wheel in every possible way is what
makes a balaboosta which is why she
named her restaurant in manhattan after
the yiddish expression what exactly does
bala booster mean it's like a perfect
housewife but for me as we are in a 21st
century it's a little bit different
somebody that can bond the family
together know to cook the best she's on
top of things
odd money grew up in israel descended
from generations of balaboostas a
lineage she embraces in her kitchen
today
her persian mother was born in iran and
her father was from yemen surrounded by
a combination of cultures near tel aviv
odmuni was influenced by a kaleidoscope
of taste what are your earliest memories
of cooking
wow kind of a nightmare i would say i
grew up in a tiny town and my parents
got super religious when i was
young like eight nine and
even before that there was always have
shabbat dinner for us imagine that you
need to do thanksgiving every week
that's a lot of food every week
throughout her youth she tried to
distance herself from the kitchen but
somehow always found herself gravitating
back around the age of 26 i'm like what
can i do that i never get bored and that
was the one thing i knew even when she
was drafted into the israeli army for
the country's mandatory two-year service
odd money was guided by her balabusto
roots in the military i started as a
driver for air force and i became a cook
when i lived in germany i was a street
seller i was living rv travel around the
europe
and then i realized that everywhere i go
i cook for everyone and i said
i should go to culinary school and that
was the best decision of my life after
working at one of israel's top
restaurants the plan was to then study
cooking in new york for three months but
life and love had other plans when she
met her now husband and business partner
stefan knuffziger the two started their
first restaurant in 2005. taim a falafel
shop you said you actually felt a slight
twinge of shame when you opened it
because imagine you work in an oh like
very three-star restaurant fine fine
dining and then you open a haddo cart in
the street but i thought i'm going to
open the falafel for three months and
then i'm going to go back to do
something else
and it was much more work than what i
thought it would be it was also more
successful than you thought it would be
it was crazy taim now has seven
locations in new york and washington d.c
but the allure of creative fine dining
never went away and in 2010 she opened
balabusta dedicated to israeli cuisine a
lot of people don't really realize what
israeli cooking is and it's it's a
million dollar question when they ask me
that what is nice about israeli cuisine
it's new cuisine it's a very new cuisine
we're very young so it's very new
cuisine that's still trying to figure
out and define itself but at the same
time we cannot forget that israel is a
melting pot of over a hundred cultures
those cultures continue to influence ad
money especially when it comes to
creating new recipes
i grew up on stuffed cabbage actually
from few different directions but here i
want to do something that have no
contain meat admoni stuffed cabbage not
to the dish her mother used to make
while the execution is new the flavors
are familiar how important is the spice
to your cooking oh my god that's
everything
that's everything i've been cold like
reno spices many many times the vibrant
dishes of bala brusta reflect tradition
and innovation like her signature fried
olives wild mushrooms on top of harissa
malay an octopus with notes of saffron
and one of adam's favorites yemenite
soup dumplings inspired by the chinese
dish known as xiao limbaugh that was
yemenite and we eat yama night soup
every friday this is made with chicken
broth and then inside there is ground
beef and hawaiian spice and then we mix
it all together
so yes well let's try it
oh that's really good it's interesting
because i'm so familiar with this dish
i've never had it like this
never like this i love to hear that
cauliflower also gets a new treatment
fried golden brown and topped with bomba
an israeli snack
but classics from home still have a
starring role like todd dig delicately
perfumed persian rice with a crispy
crust
crack it hear the crack normal food
oh that's good odd money serves ribeye's
steak with potato crisps and mustard
greens along with the stuffed cabbage
she showed us how to make a lot of these
dishes are things that you made growing
up then and then you made it your own as
you've gotten older
just to piss my mama yeah
there's also some sugar that goes with
that spice are you ready for dessert
always
baklava reimagined pistachio ice cream
dipped in a mixture of nuts wrapped in
phyllo dough and lightly fried and we
put it on this beautiful syrup so this
is baklava like you've never had it
before no you never i added yesterday
but
but this is a baklava yeah you never had
before challenging traditions in food
and life cause for celebration a drink
called liala which is in arabic mean
let's go let's go let's go and it's
something in israel everybody use it
yala move on move on
let's go cheers
today admoney says anyone not just women
can be a balaboosta the center of a
family and this restaurant is her home
this is what we're trying to do here we
were very welcoming our customers it
feel like homes the the weight stuff is
treating people like that just in my
house the food is generous we're trying
to be as kind as possible just like
keeping up the name
i promise anything
and we have brought some of that stuff
cabbage back with us so you're seeing it
in play right now and this is wise taste
of home which is delicious we have a lot
of spices in here she says he's the
queen of spice and better yet we also
brought back the yala drink so this has
yellow let's go
pineapple juice there's also i'm sorry
there's orange blossom pineapple as well
as ginger and i'm told a heavy-handed
pour of tequila yes i can confirm so be
careful uh
that just hit um
so nancy this is it's actually the first
time i've seen nancy in person here
because of the pandemic and everything
else and a great job with the dish yes
and it's so good to have you here yeah
which is nice to bring a drink we'll be
thank you very much we'll be right back
each time i find myself
flat on my face
i pick myself up as we continue eating
yes sampling she's i mean she's
wonderful yeah her story and i mean i
love how she talks about what a blend
israeli food is because people ask when
they go to israeli restaurant they don't
know exactly what they're going to get
and it's this blend of she says a
hundred different
cultures into this melting pot and you
see that mixture of things when you talk
about she had a neighbor who was
moroccan that she spent a lot of time
cooking with growing up so those tastes
all influence all the dishes that she
makes her dad's from yemen her mom's
from iran and then the soup dumpling i
love a soup dumpling all the slurping
yes and i couldn't believe how much it
looks like the chinese xiaolongbao how
do they like you know you were saying
about in during the during the piece
that they actually have their chef from
where yes they have a chef from shanghai
who is specially trained in folding
these shaolin ball because it could be
very difficult to fold it correctly and
she comes in every week and makes them
which is why they look so authentic oh
don't people you find think they know
what israeli food is
and are they mistaken
what did she say there are just so many
different influences from so many
different cultures that i don't know if
it's mistaken but it's that everyone has
a different interpretation of it i think
that's it yeah i don't think you can be
wrong necessarily because there's so
many different ways i think you're right
yeah i love how she said um you know
that she is is changing up her mom's
recipes yeah just to make her mad a
little bit
she's wicked wit nancy thanks again